you're in the uh the house what's up
yasuti
yeah hey so um so i you know i've been
very divorced i've uh dated around
you know dated younger girls
uh the stressful red flags that kind of
go with it and more recently i'm dating
i'm 36 i'm dating you know a nice girl
closer to my age
stable mentally connected but it doesn't
necessarily have the same thrills i
guess that kind of com you know that
come with my prior relationships with
the younger ones
um so i'm trying you know at my age
who's been around the block in some
aspects or another
what's to be expected of myself in the
mental state
you know of not having the thrills of
dating a 26 year old right and more of
the consistency of dating somebody
older more mature and more stable with
no relationship
uh the girl i've been seeing recently is
she's 34. so she's sorry how would you
say you were again greg 36
okay and i'm gonna point my life where
i'm looking first to build i mean i'm
looking
you know what do you mean by stability
like what do you like
i'm not looking for the weekend drama
you know the girlfriends the
club scene you know a nice
uh
nice companion to travel with i'm not
pressed to get married or have kids
anytime soon but
you know a piece just peace how long how
long have you been dating this one uh
four months now okay and she got any
kids
no no kids and uh she was engaged um
broke it off back in october
moved home to her parents house
um so at some point she's going to be
looking to buy her own place or
you know push the ball a little quicker
into moving into my home which i'm ah we
has she talked about children to you
she has yeah it's definitely something
that she she's not hard pressed to do it
you know she understands ideally the
date a year or so or more before that is
you know she's she's honestly she's uh
very understanding
well she's accommodating right now right
she's understanding right now
but that might change right i mean like
the thing at 34 is she's getting close
to the end of her
you know fertility years right
and you don't want to be an old father
like you don't want to be having a kid
when you're in your 40s your 50s because
you're going to have no energy to deal
with it right i mean you're basically
going to need a young check to do all
the
child rearing and you're just going to
be like the
20-minute dad that rolls around the
floor and plays with him you know when
he's three when he's like play with me
play with me daddy play with me and
you're like out of gas in like 25
minutes okay i know what that's like
because i just visited my brother over
the weekend and i got two nephews and
i'm playing with one of them it's like
after 25 minutes i'm like dude i'm done
all right
so
so i mean like you're dealing with a
chick that's like pretty much at the end
of a reproductive cycle and you know
she's going to be wondering like okay
you know if i'm going to have kids we
got to do it now and you're 36 you're
about the same age that i was when i had
my kid
um
so
you know your notion of like traveling
around and having a companion
dude if i'm being honest
a younger chick would be better for that
or a dog would be better for that
honestly but
like at some point
i've gotten over the years has been from
the younger girls
why do they stress you out um
just it's just a different
you work you know you date them along
the way you you know they start to
mature
uh you know it's like a double-edged
sword you're out having fun with them
one weekend and then monday through
friday you're trying to focus on work
while they still want to go and have fun
there dude there's lots of younger women
that don't want to party i live in south
florida i mean fort lauderdale miami
it's
it's
you're not finding any there
uh it's just there's a very big
difference between the way the 26 to 28
year you know are these like the same
kind of like ratchet hoes you see on
like fresh and fit where they're like
fives that think that they're nines
yeah i mean there's tons of good-looking
girls here but whether you're 20 you
know
the girls here are 24 all the way until
they're 31 32. you know
here's what i would say it's
okay yeah
they're going to stress you out if you
let them right if you have strong frame
and you're just like
no i don't deal with that
no i'm not doing that
no i don't deal with that
stop it or the door is over there you
know like you're gonna have a bunch of
them they're gonna walk in you because
they think they're hot [ __ ] right and
that's your cold diarrhea when you start
having these conversations they're gonna
push back and they're gonna test your
frame and all that sort of stuff
you got this older one now that's like
you know she's kind of burnt out she's
like you know partied she was engaged
that didn't work out she moved back home
of course she's going to be more more
compliant right now i mean she's going
to be a little bit more agreeable than
the other ones but
i mean for what you're looking for like
you're looking for a companion like
you're saying like you don't want kids
yeah i'm looking for a piece of mind you
know someone that you know she look we
live by the beach here she's she's up
for a good saturday sunday out by the i
mean she's fun to be with on the
weekends it's just i don't have that
same enthusiasm hanging out with her as
i do
the younger ones
but it at my like
greg i'm gonna tell you exactly what's
gonna happen at at some point in the
next maybe a few weeks maybe a couple of
months she's gonna be like look uh i was
engaged i want to have kids all my
girlfriends are having kids my ex is
drying up i got to do this you know like
where are we going like where do we
stand sort of thing and then your whole
oh she's a compliant you know companion
goes out the window and then you're
going to be forced to make the choice
okay well do i break up with her and go
back to a younger check that's going to
be cool with the whole travel companion
thing or do i fold and marry this chick
and start putting babies in her
well that's why i got divorced the last
time four years ago i got divorced over
the want for a kid in that immediate
moment which
i said no
um and here i am today yeah
so
do you want to have kids
uh that's kind of i don't honestly i
don't really know i i really you're not
excited about it
no i like the selfishness that kind of
goes with not having kids you're
probably better off dating a younger
chick then
and and just putting some solid frame
around her like mops in the chat and he
said something about you know it's a
frame issue don't buy it
and
you know when you get these like
chicks that push back and they want to
party they want to do this and then it's
like no i don't do that you know
if that's what you want to do then go
right i don't do that just spin a bunch
of plates until you find a younger check
that that gives you what you want right
the whole mental point of origin common
set is like i've identified this is what
i want to do this is how i want to live
my life and this we're going to go for
the next you know a few years
date a bunch of checks wait till one of
them's like greg where do we stand i
really you know dig your vibe
let them know where you stand and then
make sure that they're you know well
within your frame and they follow your
lead right yeah i think you know to that
ass a lot of this just uh
differentiate you know just not feeling
antagonized to go
you know hang out on a thursday or
sunday
dude you should join my community you'd
be a good fit there's a lot of good guys
in there around your age that are kind
of at the same spot and you know a lot
of the stuff that you're talking about
you can do with bros which in my opinion
is a very good way to do it
i mean into uh the respect you know i've
the people on here mention things about
real estate i you know i had a bunch of
commercial warehouses here in south
florida fort lauderdale that were all
just opportunities that i came
into along the way and
um
anyone that you know real estate is
certainly one of the best things that i
could advise somebody to invest their
time in
yeah well you're in a great market for
it too right
yeah it won't slow down down here for a
little bit but i appreciate your time
man i'm gonna all right bud suck it up
thanks hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you